[Alkış]
Merhabalar hepiniz hoşgeldiniz
bugün bu anlayışsız Ali başkan çok
eğlenceli Giresun'daki defa geldim o
yüzden çok keyif aldım buraya benim de
olduğum şeylerde benziyor şimdi bugün
biraz enteresan bir gün oldu benim için
çünkü daha önce izlemediğin kendi bölümü
izleme şansına sahip oldum
ve yine Milyoner ve diğer konular
gündeme geldi Şimdi ben aslında bugün
konuşmamı bildiğinizden fazlası
bilmediğimiz niye bilmediğimiz yaparken
kapandı böyle bir tasarıyı ulaşmıştır
oturan kişi olan 24 yaşındaki çocuk ya
da işte yetişkin bir de siz nasıl
görüyorsunuz
hayatınızda görüp görebileceğiniz en
kararsız ve deniz insanlardan biri en
çok kendini eleştiren kendini o kadar
sadeleştiren ve bu eleştirileri altında
baskı altında kalan Çocuklardan bir
tanesi benim kendi
ruhum meyve kendi zihnimde tasarladığım
kendime eleştirme ve kendini geliştirme
noktası bence çok önemli ve kritik nokta
ve bugün izlediğinizde de bugün videoda
gördüğünüz yasak olduğu durumda ben de
başardığın işlerden bir tanesi Bence bu
yüzden onu paylaşmak istiyorum ve bunun
da neyi bilmediğimiz nasıl ulaştı
anlatmak istiyorum şimdi herkes kendini
belli başlı konularda eleştirebilir ya
da kendini belli başlı konularda
yetersiz görebilir ve bütün
yetersizlikler ile beraber nasıl başa
çıkacağını bilemeye bilir işin daha
enteresanın bazen insanlar kendi
canlıların ya da kendi durumlarını kendi
sahip olduklarını ve kendi edin diye
dönemleri de eleştirebilir ki bu konuda
ben gerçekten çok başarılıydı gün içinde
tahmin edemeyeceğin kadar çok kendime
değiştirdim kendimi beğenmem Tahsin
olmam mutsuz olurum ne yapacağım bilemem
ama tüm güçlerin ortasında
zihnimi de çok kritik ve çok önemli
olduğuna inandım bir kelime üzerine Her
şeyi sil baştan başlatabilirim insanlar
Bu kullandığım zaman bu kalıp yaz
enteresan belli oluyor
Ondan dolayı biraz anlaşılmaz oluyor
ben sana
yaklaşmak istiyorum
insanın zihninde olan insanın kendi
vicdanını yargıç olarak kullandı ve tüm
fikirleri tüm düşünceleri tüm duyguları
Metin dağılışlarını uygulamada ve
kendi yargıyla bir davaya konu ettiği
bir durum ve tutum şimdi adalet dediğim
zaman özel nazilliadalet dediğim zaman
bu da şunu fark etmemiz gerekiyor örnek
veriyorum üniversite sınavına giren
öğrenciler ya da herhangi bir hepimiz
bunu biliyoruz ki sınavda genellikle
beşik oluyor ve bu Beşiktaş'ın abcde
gibi pek çok var ya sorma Tamam ve erken
gelelim aşkını çoğunluk seçtim yani
Buradaki tüm katılımcıların hepsi
aşıkını bir tek ben
bu sorunun doğru cevabını aşık olduğunu
kanıtlar mı
peki sadece benim pembe size zorla ve
dayatma ile değişik bunun doğru olduğuna
inandım ya da şiddetle baskıyla 510
seçmenize sağlam yine 5 yaşında olduğunu
katem
ben seni Cevap alır sorununda IŞİD'den
oluşması sorun başka bir cevabı olmasına
kanıtlar mı
Belki daha iyi bir Facebook'a at kimse
bilemez burada insanların arasında bizim
toplumumuzda sistemleriniz artık bunu da
tardan benim bulduğum düşünüyorum yani
düşüncelerde adaletsizlik biz artık
toplumda adaleti olabiliyordu iyi yer
göster sahip olabiliyoruz dünyanın pek
çok ülkesinde daha İyiler düzeylerde
olabiliyor ve geliştirme biliyor ama
insanlar olarak zihnimizde ve içimizdeki
yargıçlığı içimizdeki düşünceler
arasındaki tutarlılık ve tutarsızlığı
dürüst bir şekilde bir duruşmada
sergileme konusunda bence de sıkıntı
çekiyoruz bu noktaya değinmek hem sitesi
pek çok konuda ve pek çok alanda sizin
daha doğru karar vermesi
gibi örnekleri
verebilirsiniz
halkın çoğunluğunun aşıkım seçmesi niye
sorun Aşkın doğru olduğunu ispat etmeye
bilir bu doğru bir şey olabilir ama
çoğunluğunu sadece ayşekadın seçtiği
için aşıktın kabul etmeyiz Burada bazı
problemler yazıyor çünkü sorunca başka
değilse biz sadece bir çoğunluğun
8245 ile gitmiş olacağız
sorunlardan diğeri de dediğin gibi bir
azından seçtiğini soruyor Doğru cevaplar
iddia edip ve bunun Canısı artık Peki
buna bir çözüm bulabiliriz şöyle bir şey
dememiş acaba uzmanlığını bulsak bu
soruyla ilgili uzmanların problemi
çözecek uzmanları bulsak ve bunlara
soracağını sor durursak o zaman mümkün
olabilir miyim soru cevabı Belki de
farklı çıktı ve o uzman bu sorun Işıklı
daha iyi gelebilirdi bulamıyorum ama
burada bazı sorunlar var burada da bazı
sıkıntılar var şöyle
uzmanında hata yapma ihtimali olduğunu
kabul etmek zorundayız
bu hata yapma ihtimalini sadece onun
sırtına gitmeyi bu seçimde Onun bir
parçası olduğunu Çünkü tüm bunları bir
araya getirdiğimizde temel sonuç
olduğunu farkettik doğru çıktı seçme
konusunda doğrunun tanımı konusunda
eksiklerimiz var ya da ne olduğunu
bilmiyoruz ya da doğru dediğimiz şey çok
çok pislik değil ne olduğuna emin ol ama
biliyoruz Ya da hepimiz farklı
olabiliyor burada Aslında
benim
en sevdiğim sözlerden bir tanesini
alıntı yapmak istiyorum Bunu söyleyen
kişi söyle ne düşündüğü müzik
ve resim eserlerinde geçiyordum Şimdi
bunu demokrasi rogarlar Sak onların
Atina'nın demokrasi anlayışını
ayarlarsak hafta kendiniz dinimizde
dikilen arasındaki demokrasi nasıl
sağlayabileceğimiz mantıklı şekilde
anlayabiliriz
hepimiz diyor tüm yurttaşlar diyor
Stratejik plan proje ortaya koymaya
bilir
plana uygun şekilde Düzgün şekilde
uyarlamaya da uygulama konusunda
başarılı olamayabilir hepimiz olsan
yöneticilik vasıflarına sahip
olamayabilirim
aramızdan bir ya da birileri bu
vasıflara sahip olup bu işleri
götürebilir güzel ama geri kalan tüm
yurttaşlar onu yargılama yolunun
hatalarını söylemeyeceğine sahip işte
burada soruya bakın kızın hatasını
üzerine sevmiş oluruz biz doğru
geliyoruz Eve doğru yorarken istisnasız
bir şekilde hiç değişmeyecek ki doğru
yapıyoruz
Çünkü belki de doğru bizim sandığımız ve
bizim sokmayı çalıştığımız kalıptaki bir
doğru değil Belki de doğru sürekli
değişen bir şey ona bu fırsatı tanımamız
gerekiyor o zaman şunu önerebilirsin
kayboldunuz bitirir sahip olduğumuz
düşünceye sahip olduğumuz yönetim biçimi
ya da sahip olduğumuz dediği Her neyse
tamam onu deneyelim Ama onun karşındaki
tüm gücümüzle kuvvetimizi Buyur taşta
bulabilir zihnimizdeki diğer bütün güzel
olabilir Bunları mevcut olan düşünceyi
yanlışlama ya Onu düzeltmeye onu
eleştirme yönetim ve bu sayede bir
sorunun doğru cevabını piçle koşam 1A
grubunun tek en çoğunluk B grubu Seçen
azınlık yerine sorunun nasıl değiştiğine
sonra ne kadar fazla şişko olabileceğini
ve buçuktan arasında hangisinin giderek
daha da oraya yakın olabileceğini
yanlışlar metoduyla bulabildik bir sürü
insan hali dedim bu adalet anlayışında
en önemli kavram ortaya koyuyor çünkü
Bence adalet anlayışı en çok yakışan
kavram verimlilik Eğer bir şey gelirse
ve daha birini olabiliyorsa Demek ki o
adalet sistemi içinde belirlediği öne
çıkabilen ve bizim herhangi öyle
çıkartabiliriz bir şey şimdi derken
derken
bir dakika konuşabilir miyiz
insanı da tasarruf etmiyoruz ama sudan
tasarruf ediyor zeytin hasat ediyoruz
ama insan beyninden tasarruf etme
konusunda da onu beni mi kullanmak olsun
Bugün Keklikler içindeyiz Çünkü bizim
kafamıza tek bir doğruyu
inandığımız doğruyu sert ve ciddi
şekilde savunma konusunda çok tipik
davranış taşıdı bulunuyor Ve bu
davranışlara sahip olduğunuz zaman
hayatını size getirdiği zor sorular da
ya da hayatın sessiz kalma şekilde
değişik problemlerde farklı sorunlara
farklı cevaplar üretime sürekli cevap
verdim ve o cevapları bulduktan sonra da
yine sorulara Özgür'ü de Suriye gitme
olanlarla insan alıyorsunuz karşıda
Duran adamın karısı olması sebeplerinden
bir tanesi de Kürdüm her işimizi
sebeplerinden biri de belki ikili
gibiler
ne kadar temkinli bir insandır
hayatın her anında her şeyi de her
düşünceli yanında biri olduğunu kabul
edildi
oraya giderken
[Müzik]
problem değil Sonuçta benim oraya
giderken kafamda oturdu oturdu hayatım
için yaşarken belli bir mantığa ve
temele dayandığını ve deney olarak
sunabileceği geri dönüşler alabileceğim
bir fikrim var ve bu fikirlerimi
deneyerek de bazı sonuçlar elde edip
kendini geliştirme imkanı tanıyorum
Acaba kitlediler kendi fikirlerimi
sadece benim oldukları için onları bu
adaletsizlik ile öne çıkartmak dansa
sözlükten daha iyi yerse yer Yine başa
geçmelerine izin veriyorum zaten farkına
konuşsanız
en büyük fark şu
12 0'dan 10'a kadar da insan düşünün
fakir daha az fakir orta halli zengin
çok zengindir ona kadar sıkıldık burada
giriş misin Yavru kedinin Aslında kur
un kademesindeki zengin çocuğuna ve 0'ın
kademesindeki fakirin çocuğunu
aldıkları imkanlar ve şartlarla 0'dan
10'a ondan da 0 düşmesine izin verecek
özgürlük ve adalet ortamı sağlamak
bizim gibi ülkelerde ya da dünyanın pek
çok ülkesinde Daha doğrusu sınıfındaki
bir çocuğun girebileceği 576 geçmiyor
ideal şartlarda ama eğer bir insanı Eğer
Çalışmak istiyorsan ve başarmak
istiyorsan ona taşıyabilecek ve Ondaki
insanı da Eğer çalışmıyorsa başlar mı
yoksa uğraş Yunus'a sıfıra indirecek
Adalet sistemini yargılama
dünyada Kimse gelip o zaman ikimiz
yaparsak kendi zihninizde bize 0'da
bırakan ve o da onu olmasına izin
vermeyen adaletsiz düşecek sistemi yok
edipte Her kitle fırsat verirsek bunları
dönersek ve bu deneme sonucunda da
onları özgürce ve etik bir yargılama
şansına muktedir olursak o zaman demek
ki hayatın birçok alanında Andımız
düşündüğümüzde onlardan farklı olarak
pek çok yanlış bu yanlış yazdım
öğrenebilir öğrendiklerimizle Yeni
şeyler keşfedebilir yeni kişilerin bize
de merak duygumuzu halk duygumuzu
giderebiliriz Çünkü bu hayatın Kendisi
de vardır bebekte olduğu zaman kimse
bilmez çok hasta gibi daha doğrusu Ama
bebek Önce Ekmekler emeklemeyi keşfeder
ve bundan hazır daha sonra yürümeye
Belki de ondan da hazır baksana
konuşmayı annesine konuşmayı parkta
koşmayı keşfeder ve bundan daha büyük
azalır Eğer yaşaması ile gelir de
okumaya geçiyorlar odanda azalabilir
eğer doğru bir şekilde onay getirsek
Belki de insanla dünyaya çevresine
iyilikler ve güzellikler saçmak ve daha
güzel bir çevre bırakmak için de
azalabilir Demek ki bunların hepsi çok
bu dünyada bugün
gördüğümüz
olumsuz olarak düşündüğümüz fikirler
kadar mümkün O zaman bu fikirlerin
Adalet sağlamak Bu fikirlerine dünyada
Adil olması ve gerektiği hakkı ve
özgürlük tanımasını sağlamak Bizim kendi
görevimiz Müsait olduğunda değil kendi
ikimize de yapmamız gerekiyor Bu yüzden
ben bir iş yaparken ya da birlikte
uğraşırken
ekran kazanayım da tekrar söylediğin
gibi yarışmada yarışırken pek çok
seçenek olabilir çekilebilirim
kaybedebilirim kazanabilirim ama ben
orada burada bekleriz ne olduğunu bu
sene şeker olası sonuçlarını beni nereye
götüreceğini ve duygularımı
düşüncelerimi bile hangisine seçime
içeceğini düşünme Orası bir yargı Handır
Benim vicdanım yargıçtır elindeki bilgi
dedim Peki bilgilerim en doğru ve en
bana yararlı olabilecek şekilde seçmeye
çalıştım ve sonra da karar verin buysa
benim kendimi sürekli eleştirmem ve
kendimi eleştirmem ile ilgili kurduğum
sanatsal biçim Bence bir isim Sen
yapabileceği en ama en önemli
katkılardan bir tanesi Çünkü kapalı
örnek verirsek Biz arasında 1.000
vermeniz kaba bir mermer çok kaba ama
aynı zamanda da onun mermeri dövmesi o
mermeri [ __ ] sabirow Mermere şeker
vermesi gereken sanatçılarımız mermerden
mi Saat 8'e kendimiz olmamız gerekiyor
ama bunu yapmak bir daha zor Çünkü ne
zaman yudumda şekil vermek için mermeri
olacak o Balyoz Aslında vücudumuzda
kendi değiştirmek bize zor geliyor Çünkü
ne zaman kendimize şekil vermeye
Çalışsak bir parçamız Copa biliyor o
yüzden çok insan kafalı mermerlerde
kalmayı tercih ediyorum ama Oysa çok az
insan kendini mükemmel bir de geri
dönüştürmek için ciddi çaba sarf ediyor
bence kafa mermer iyi bir tane sen
dönüşmek için gerekli çabayı ve gerekli
özveriyi sonuna kadar hakediyor
Tokat etseydiniz tanıyorsunuz oraya
girdim duymuşsunuzdur
benim kendimde hayatım Şimdi yürürken
Parti için
çabalarken davetin için de bir şeyler
elde etmeye çalışırken çok sevdiğin
hikayesi varsa o kadar çok insan
Sokrates'in idamında dolayı tanır ve
Sokrates'in idamında pilotunun yazdı O
Epic sahnelerini hatırlar Feto'nun Bir
de sokarız en büyük 30 kitabını nereden
sadece birinde yazılar dışında tüm
kitaplarını Sokrates vardır ve
Sokrates haklı olduğu için ölmesinden
korkmaması filan çok etektir ama
ve benimle puan Sokrates'in Sokrates
yapan ve beni ona hayran bırakan asıldan
sohbet et 430 yılında
kayraform diye bu adamın derslik haline
gitmesiyle hayatını değiştiriyor şöyle
oluyor adam belki yanına gittiğinde
kaynak şunu soruyor Atina'nın en iyi
adamı kim
çok zorsun cevap veriyor istiyorum
ama
sohbete göre Sokrates'in en büyük
olmasının sebebi kıymetini biliniz en
büyük olmadığını biliyorum Bunun için de
çaba sarf edebileceğine soru
sorabileceğim bunu kabul etmektense bunu
kabul etmeyip sorular sorarak kendini
yenilemeyi geliştirmeyi öğrenmeyi tercih
edebileceğini biliyor bu Atina
demokrasisi
[Müzik]
düzeyinin ortaya çıkmasındaki Bence
anahtar kelimelerden biri o dönemin
insanları bizim bu dönemde de yakın
dönemde gördüm sana da farklı olarak bir
şeylere sarılmak ve bir şeylerin peşinde
sonsuza kadar konuşmak kafeden düşmek
yerler bir şeyde Nusret değişmesini
farklılaşmasını ve doğal olarak
farklılaştı içinde daha farklı şeylere
ulaşmasını tercih ediyor bunun peşini
dürüstçe koşu var bu adalet sistemi ve
bu fikirler Bence bizim Neyi
bildiğimizden çok neyi bilmediğimiz
önemli bizim için iyi bir sebep
yarışmada gördüğünüz kişi çok
ilgilenmiyordu ya da bizim kazandıktan
sonra da olur da nereye düşersin
ilgilenmiyordu
merak ediyordum O yüzden 12 tane
soruyorsun daha fazla gelseydi İnanın
bana o gün daha da çok benzin beklersin
benim hasta ki tulum işte tamam mı
olarak bundan ibaret Ben
olan olayların beni değerlendirmesi de
değil kendimi Türkçe değerlendirdiğini
de ne olduğumu ilgileniyorum ve bunun
içinde Neyi bilmediğim Araştırıyorum ben
girmedim araştırdığın varsa o kadar
vermedi çok iyi dövüyor
Umarım Sizler tarafından güzel bir
saatte sana dönüşüyorum dur da öyle
görüyorum tur
atmaya çalışmak istiyorum çünkü
zihinlerde Adil olmak insanın kendi
olmak bu insanların depresyonları ve
kaygıları ST Bozukları gibi sorunlar
Aslında birebir çözüm Bizler Eğer
kendimiz attınız edersek baz
duygularımızın deposit oldukları içmeyi
depresifin kolay olduğu için ön plana
çıkarıp Aslı hayatta bizi tutacak
hayatın güzelliklerini gösterecek
duyguların önüne geçildiğini ve onları
engellemeden izin verirsek bu
adaletsizlik ortamı sağlarsak o zaman
biten azabı çeken Çünkü vicdanınız bu
kadar sizi sessiz kalmamalı
ve bu sabunun peşinde iyi bir fikir
ilgili felsefi düşünce koymak Bence her
insanın kendi arasında uygulamaya
çalışması ve bundan dolayı da hem
özgüvenle hem gibi karakterli Hem de
kendi de anlamış Ve kendini tamamlama
yakın bir insan olarak ortaya çıkması
için çok Elzem bir dur
ölmek istiyorum aslında
insanların size olan eleştirisi de
kıymetli beleştir ama şurada şuna
bineriz gerek yok ki o insanların
yaptığı eleştirileri çoğunda insanlar
size empatik olmuyor ve kendi gözüyle
bakıyor ve içinizdeki ekledim sonra
anlayamıyor Adana'da Zorluk çekiyor Bu
yüzden insanların eleştirilerine anlamak
ve insanı değiştiren dinlemek benzin çok
keyiflidir
bunu fotoğrafımı eleştirin eleştirilen
eleştirmek için uğraşır Çünkü her
eleştir gibiydi parçasıdır ve yanlışa
doğru bir şey olma ihtimali Barındırır
Ama ciddi eleştiriler de de
önemsiz alakasız eleştirilerde de
kendinize haksızlık etmeyin ve yine
adaleti sağlamak için vicdandır göre
karım
aynı mahkemede iki farklı bir musluktan
bulunabilirim bu sorun değil sonuçta
karar verecek olan Adil olacak olan
sizsiniz sonra dayak dinleyebilirim
savunmalarını yapmaları izin verebilir
onları anlamaya çalışıyorlar ve bunun
sonucunda da kendi karakterinizi en
uygun olduğuna inanan karar vermekte
aynı şekilde Dirayet ve sabah
gösterebilirsiniz bu da Bence benim
hayatımda sohbetetsem benzettiğim ve
yapmaktan seksin ve yapmaktan keyif
aldım ve Bugün sizlerle konuşuyor kendi
hayatının geri kalanı da Kendini çekip
değiştirmeye
farklılaştırmaya çalışırken elde ettiğim
ve uygulaması kararlı oldum en
Neyi
bilmediğiniz çok ama çok iyi bir öğrenme
sebebi
[Müzik]
[Alkış]